fix your body sheet to make it look like
a shirt
April bring them on through April I
review my half month favorites
everyone does their favorites at the end
of the month I'm gonna do a half month
favorites because I just forget here are
the things I like right now this QC [ __ ]
it is a cucumber herbal alcohol-free
toner from Keele so many words it's
green and when you put it on any serve
like cotton pad or something that you're
gonna like your face off with it's green
and it makes you feel like you're
putting the sewage water on your face
but like really expensive sewage water
you are like a upper-middle-class
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle otherwise I
like this it's not that harsh on my skin
and it's smells not terrible in tandem
with that I have this you see it says
yeah this is the Kiel skin resurrector
what oh no rescuer it hasn't died and
resurrected heal skin rescuer skin
minimising daily hydrator basically an
expensive white substance that I think
is working well for my skin next this
case yeah you see they say this is
Maybelline eye studio gel eye liner a
black gel eyeliner I really do think is
like a dupe for expensive jailers I like
this a lot a lot of you have been
complimenting my eyeliner on the past
couple videos hi thanks and it's because
of this fun friend next I have this new
phone it's the Nokia icon phone it is a
step up from the elephant that I had
before that I love you commented on and
the video quality of this phone haha
same see how amazing the video quality
is look how crisp and clear what's this
oh my god I can zoom in okay oh all
sleep
if you love it next cameo us a mint
so an ass I don't know
pretzel snacks these are called pretzel
Crips what they're not a gang anyway
these are prep done they're great
they're delicious
whatever